have you ever had people get wild and
try to intimidate you and then they'll
be like I want my [__] car
man well everybody that needs a toe is
generally in a not so great mood
[Music]
cuz all right I'm going to tell you guys
about a a really uh genius scam but
don't do it okay don't even think you
invented it huh you wild zany guy dude
no it's not me Z Ryan but um it's when I
read about this I was actually pretty
impressed so um whenever there's areas
that have like natural disasters like
storms floods Quakes anything that
requires like a guy to go out there and
immediately help with something like
whether it's uh drain the water from a
house that's flooded or like move Rubble
out of the way or something uh there's
people very bad people that they will
create these fake business listings in
those areas localize the contact info
for like the vulnerable places and um
they'll just make like a fake water
damage company and then that way when
everybody's super slammed and there's
like nobody that can come out they'll
like they'll be like yeah I can come out
I just got to get a upfront fee so that
you know cuz to move you up on the list
or whatever wow and nobody ever comes
and they
just it's pretty crazy how do we get
into these businesses it doesn't last
very long but there's places that have
such seasonal Dependable situations that
will always happen that they just do it
every year yeah so like worldwide
they're watching the news like it's
stocks and they go fire Maui here he
goes a hurricane uh earthquake in Japan
yeah exactly so in Davenport Iowa
there's a trend that kind it like this
scam like leveled up slightly and it's
with tow companies
yay but I thought you would find this
interesting cuz the way they did it is
that they would do it at these uh they
would uh find these places where they
know that the snow is going to be so bad
that people are going to need to get
their you know like their car cars
pulled out or moved out of like ditches
or places that are two like oh no so
people that actually need help they're
calling and they're stranded and they're
like we'll come pick you up and then
they never [__] show up and then they
frozen in the car cuz they didn't do
willhoff technique that's like a real
toe company
anyways never show up what an evil
laughter yeah that's evil that's
evil I know you think you're the
authority because you own a toe company
but I'm going to let you know right now
every time time I call Tria a they
always come through they do I work with
triple A yeah they're great Tria Triple
A is not coming Tria a is sending
someone to come they're sending me yeah
but then their trucks say AAA on it they
own zero tow trucks oh that's [__]
man zero tow trucks they contract it's
not the triple a tow trucks oh man what
they do though is if you don't get there
in 35 minutes they will cut your
contract bro they send caramel Towing
every time they're responsive man I like
tripa well whatever they do they make
sure that the tow truck guys are in line
yeah they do good job cuz what do they
do if you [__] up we're not giving you
the contract and we're not giving you
customers is that what happens that's
exactly what happens see that's like the
mafia they're big on service if we don't
get a 90% uh survey rating or higher
they they put us on and then if we don't
improve they cut us that cut throw and
if we if we lose our AAA contract we're
we're effed cuz they're the only ones
that give you they're a major they bring
the business
I put it on my Ig story I I called a tow
truck to pick my car up and then right
when the guy got there the Tria guy his
truck broke down and a bigger tow truck
had to come get him no way yeah dude
there's there's some crazy tow trucks
out there and I was like dude what if
this chain continues and there's just
like a giant ass truck a tank that
happened to me when I drove into Big
Bear Lake oh no way yeah I was uh tow
truck broke so I had a truck his truck
is Big it's probably to truck probably
showed up was like I can't do this I had
a truck trck had a truck like this one
but it was black uh and then um so I
thought the lake is only where it's wet
but apparently Big Bear Lake is just the
area so when the water receded I was
like oh [__] yeah I'm going to [__]
fly through here I go it looks dry but
then all of a sudden it's mud and then
my truck sinks all the way down so
pretty much if I where I open the the
door it'll scrape the top of the mud and
when I jump out I go into my knees
immediately and then so they bring in
it's like quick decided to just get off
the road because the the water had
receded so you're like [__] it I'm going
to cut this way that's the
attitude what's the point of having a
truck if you can't do that right and
then I guess the that was illegal so
like the [__] San Bernardino PD they
called the tow truck to come and then
they they uh had a Jeep like a hooked up
Jeep they hooked it up to my truck yeah
and then they pulled the winch and then
as it was pulling the winch the winch
pulled the Jeep into the mud oh so then
they had to bring this
big ass [__] truck that stays on the
road that has these like tripod legs
that come out so it lifts the wheels off
the ground and then he comes and then he
hooks onto the Jeep and the Jeep hooks
onto my car and then he pulled all of
this and then the whole time Gio's just
like I told you not to drive in there
and look what happened what you say back
what' you say back I want to hear that
part come on I'm a man I make
mistakes so so let me tell you about how
they leveled up they've leveled up this
scam by instead of making fake companies
what they do is they go to these areas
uh digitally and they just copy the same
exact info from the existing companies
and just make hella other listings so
people are now confused what's the real
number so when they'll like they'll uh
let's say that they're calling for
Monson towing or whatever in Davenport
there's going to be like 16 Monson
Towing and only one of them is real and
the rest of them are just like okay yeah
just shoot us this upfront B but the
real Monson doesn't even take upfront
bees yeah see that's why they need to
have a verified check mark next to
the and then you got to pay for that you
know probably be way too much work for
like the actual mons anonio or whatever
to like [__] put seas in desist or
anything like that for all these other
it's like nonstop it just keep why
people just got to use Yelp or something
cuz a lot of these people that are doing
this are not even in the area they may
not even be in the they might be like
Russian even worse might be Russian even
worse bunch of Russians have been moving
to Idaho there's actually a lot of
Russians in the midwest yeah Anthony
yeah that's what I said I literally said
a bunch of Russian have been moving Idol
bet you didn't know that hey you're a
man I'm a man we make mistakes so it's a
crazy Trend that's kind of happening now
in every place that has like these uh
little things you might start seeing
them any area that has something that
needs an immediate response is now
getting clone that's so sad people need
help and you scam the people that need
help well I mean if someone asked me for
a deposit I'll be like damn yeah all
right I'll give it to you when you come
here is that a thing where like let's
say you're super slammed right and this
guy calls and he's like hey man let me
just pay a little bit just put me on top
of the list and just get here now would
you guys even consider bump me up uh we
wouldn't consider it but we get offers
for that all the time but we do have
people pay before we do the service cuz
what happens is sometimes you'll do the
service and they be like yeah I ain't
paying you bye and you do the service
for nothing so we actually do have to
take prepayment is that when you use
knuckle service yeah he like sir I know
you're a little short on cash but you
seem a little hungry so what happens
when someone does that when they when
they get you tow their car for them and
they're just like I got no money what do
you do oh we don't get the uh we we
don't we keep the car on the truck until
until they pay yes we don't even let the
car off the truck have you ever had
people get wild and try to intimidate
you m and then they'll be like I want my
[__] car
man well every body that needs a toe is
generally in a not so great mood cuz
they don't expect to meet it so they're
already irritated and so and sometimes
like they'll have to wait 3 hours I've
had people wait like 3 days on the
freeway in an RV you know um before
somebody would come and help cuz now um
there's less tow trucks there's less tow
drivers and so everything's impacted um
and then so it used to be 35 minutes for
Triple A but in some areas they're
waiting 3 hours why is there less did
all the Armenians go like to Europe or
something or um the labor force ID is is
down people don't want to work as much
anymore everybody want to do everybody
wants to do their own thing so
everyone's driving door Dash or
something now yeah everybody's an Uber
driver everybody's doing everybody's
trying to be an influencer like
entrepreneur entrepreneur yeah dude
everybody is there's another like the
people that would have done tow truck is
like out there doing travel Vlogs or
something they're [__] dancing on Tik
Tok or they're getting government Aid
you know that's probably homeless people
a lot of them want to stay homeless
because they're getting taken care of
they have a cell phone they get a
monthly stip in yeah they get a cell
phone and then a lot of these homeless
people have two cell phones they have
their personal and they have one from
the government bur phon and they they
have internet too I get one of these
government phones got to give up your
home so they're they're not really
incentivized to get off of the street
yeah it's tough you know um and so the
biggest thing is a lot of people are
moving now but it's uh it's it's me it's
it's it's mental mental issues that are
keeping them out there like why do you
want to live on the street well I mean
if you could choose between driving a
tow truck and being yelled at every day
or living in a tent with two cell phones
I choose the camping imag all the
scrolling and you make the same amount
of money what a strange Choice yeah Tik
Tok Instagram Tik Tok is like dude I'm
set there's like another story about
this one it was like a big rig truck
this happened like yesterday where um it
was in the snow and the truck had like
Jack knifed or something and it was
stuck like perpendicular on the road
just blocking the whole road so this guy
called the tow truck and the police and
nobody came he called I think at 7 oh no
he called at 1:00 p.m.
and nobody came it was 700 a.m. that
he's still there by his truck and then
these people who were like commuting
they stopped and they went hey man do
you need help and the guy's like yeah
man my truck's stuck I'm trying to call
no one's coming and they're like okay
hang on those people left they came back
with more people and they looted the
truck no [__] way yeah oh so s where
was this at I forgot what what state
this was but that's a Mad Mac [__] dude
they looted the truck before they went
to work
I thought they were going to come back
with the tow truck like they Heroes I
was like oh no the thieves at that point
are you allowed to shoot them all I mean
he didn't he didn't do anything he just
kind of like I guess he tried to fight
them off and then but then they had
already jacked hell of [__] and then
they they left like once they got
stuff I mean these days things are
interesting huh people be like stealing
and then you if you if you beat them up
you get in deeper trouble there a lot of
people that are like being good citizens
like there was that one guy in the train
that held down that homeless man and now
he's going to go to jail and [__] and
then you get fired if you help if you
help stop theft the guy who like choked
that one dude yeah it was it was in
Memphis and it was an Amazon truck oh no
oh maybe that's why he's like ah you
could steal it I don't care it's Amazon
truck how would like save some for me
dude if I was a plumber that [__]
[__] they're taking my tools and [__]
I'd be like hell people steal tools yeah
I'll [__] eat a mushroom and beat
them up dude but why would you be a
plumber if you could just have tent with
two
phones